el esqueleto se compone de huesos que
proporcionan apoyo y dan forma al cuerpo
estos protegen a los órganos internos
blandos como el cerebro y el corazón de
una lesión
junto con los músculos los huesos
fuertes permiten al cuerpo moverse con
libertad
los huesos tienen una superficie
exterior sólida denominada hueso
compacto el hueso interior se denomina
hueso esponjoso porque es menos denso
que el hueso compacto y tiene muchos
agujeros pequeños como una esponja
los huesos contienen células denominadas
osteoclastos que descomponen el tejido
óseo otras células denominadas
osteoblastos elaboran tejido óseo nuevo
utilizando minerales como calcio y
fosfato de la sangre
las hormonas como el estrógeno la
hormona de crecimiento y la testosterona
ayudan a mantener la cantidad de
osteoblastos y su actividad en índices
superiores que los osteoclastos de
manera que se elabore más hueso del que
se elimina las fuerzas físicas y la
presión durante el ejercicio también
ayuda a que los huesos se hagan más
fuertes y más densos
estos procesos permiten que los huesos
crezcan fuertes en niños y adultos
jóvenes las personas tienen sus huesos
más fuertes y densos lo que se denomina
pico de masa ósea a sus 30 años después
de esta edad los osteoclastos se
eliminan gradualmente más hueso del que
los osteoblastos se elaboran
la osteoporosis es una enfermedad que
debilita los huesos y produce que éstos
se rompan con mayor facilidad un hueso
sano es lo suficientemente denso como
para soportar y proteger al cuerpo y
para manejar las tensiones del
movimiento y lesiones menores sin
embargo las personas con osteoporosis
tienen huesos anormalmente delgados con
orificios más grandes en el hueso
esponjoso
hay dos tipos de osteoporosis
la osteoporosis primaria generalmente
relacionada con la edad avanzada así
como una cantidad reducida de estrógeno
en las mujeres
la osteoporosis secundaria afecta a
niños y adultos
está relacionada con otras enfermedades
o afecciones como el cáncer problemas
hormonales o el uso de determinados
medicamentos
una persona tiene mayor riesgo de
contraer algún tipo de osteoporosis si
no desarrolla suficiente masa ósea
durante su crecimiento desde la infancia
hasta la edad adulta los factores de
riesgo que pueden conducir a un pico de
baja masa ósea incluyen los siguientes
antecedentes familiares de osteoporosis
ser de raza blanca o asiático
ser mujer
una mala alimentación determinados
medicamentos como los esteroides o
ciertos medicamentos para convulsiones
la falta de actividad física y los
ejercicios de levantamiento de pesas y
los hábitos de vida como fumar y el
consumo excesivo de alcohol
una persona tiene mayor riesgo de
contraer algún tipo de osteoporosis si
tiene una cantidad anormal de pérdida
ósea después de los 30 años de edad es
normal algo de pérdida ósea después de
esta edad sin embargo una persona con
los mismos factores de riesgo para el
pico de masa ósea baja puede ser más
propensa a sufrir de osteoporosis a
medida que envejece el aumento de
pérdida ósea también es común en las
mujeres después de su último período
denominado menopausia
después de la menopausia los ovarios de
una mujer dejan de producir la hormona
estrógeno con la disminución de las
hormonas las células que descomponen el
hueso denominadas osteoclastos están más
activas que las células que elaboran
hueso denominadas osteoblastos es
posible que los huesos se rompan o se
fracturen fácilmente porque son
incapaces de soportar la tensión física
y la presión de las actividades incluso
normales los lugares comunes de fractura
en personas con osteoporosis incluyen
las muñecas la columna vertebral y las
caderas
si se desarrollan huesos fuertes y
saludables mediante una alimentación
rica en calcio y vitaminas y una
actividad física regular se puede ayudar
a prevenir ya tratar la osteoporosis
los medicamentos comunes para la
osteoporosis incluyen bifosfonatos
un medicamento denominado denosumab
moduladores selectivos de los receptores
estrogénicos o srm y la calcitonina
en general estos medicamentos actúan
sobre las células óseas de eliminación
denominadas osteoclastos la hormona
paratiroidea actúa sobre las células
óseas de eliminación denominadas
osteoblastos los alimentos o suplementos
que contienen calcio y vitamina d
también se recomiendan para la
osteoporosis
para obtener más información consulte a
un profesional de la salud